hello internet creatures i'm dave rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
it's february 4th
2022 which falls on a friday and that
reminds me to give you a little
housekeeping update starting next friday
we will be back
to our panel shows that's when i bring
on three people in three different
locations to talk about three different
topics uh i know you guys were digging
them i enjoy doing them and we finally
got all our equipment in order and next
friday we will start with that again
today we are doing a q a and we got
dozens of questions over at
reubenreport.locals.com that will
officially move to thursdays where it's
been it happens to be on friday today i
appreciate all your patience as we've
rolled all this stuff out and before we
get to the q a uh there was a great
story yesterday this is just like one of
those stories
or one of those little media bites that
i'm just like this is why i do what i do
because you guys know that while i am a
mild-mannered talker an internet head
whatever you want to call it a youtuber
a guy who talks about politics or
whatever
what i really wanted to be was a
basketball player i am now 45 years old
i have a torn acl in my left knee i can
still shoot i can get to the hoop a
little bit if i've got the brace but i
wanted to be an nba player and shaquille
o'neal is one of the greatest nba
players of all time i'd say top two or
three center of all time maybe wilt and
hakeem in front of him i don't wanna i
don't wanna start a fight anyway shaq in
the last you know 15 years since he
retired roughly has been on nba on tnt
which uh is where they analyze you know
he's with charles barkley and kenny
smith and ernie johnson this is where
they analyze what's going on in the
world and shaq's become a pretty good
broadcaster he's outspoken on a lot of
issues well shaq went on a podcast
on cbs it's called the big podcast
hosted by nichelle turner i don't know
her or the podcast but he went on the
podcast and they started talking about
vaccine mandates and shaq i love you man
look i encourage everybody to be safe
and take care of your family i do
but there's still some people that don't
want to take it and you shouldn't have
to be forced to take something that you
don't want so i don't think people are
being forced to take well there are some
there are i mean listen we have a
mandate at cbs that's forced we have a
mandate at cbs but my but my point is
force but where i wholeheartedly that's
forest no it's not force it is poor
because if the man don't take it a man
will get fired
i love the guy shaq i hope you see this
you're awesome dude i also saw a video
of shaq about a week and a half ago oh
here's shaq look at this this is shack
we just threw this in this is him just
ripping down hoops while he's dunking i
think we got three of them for you look
at this look at this just rip it
the glass on his head we got one more
one more i remember this one off his
yeah oh
beautiful there's like there's like 20
30 of those where he just demolishes
backboards it's a beautiful thing
shaq there was a video you may have seen
like a week or two ago where he's at a
mall and a guy is buying a ring for his
girlfriend an engagement ring and he
apparently shaq overheard the guy
basically saying you know i got to do
this in payment plans or whatever and
shaq just bought it for the guy right
there like he's just a good guy i've
never heard anyone say anything bad
about shaq but that's just such a
beautiful thing uh because you know he's
like look people have to make decisions
for themselves i don't believe people
should be forced into anything and she's
like well we don't for ah well i guess
we do have a sports thing here over at
cbs and uh yeah and shaq is just saying
what the simple truth is and we live in
an odd time where we have to find sense
from seven foot one former nba
superstars who are making more sense
than say the guy leading the nih or the
ceo
of the cdc or anyone basically in
mainstream media i think you guys know
my feelings on this but of course you
should not be forced to take anything
you want and the idea that your company
can force you to be injected with
something once twice three times couple
extra boosters it's just so ridiculous
so shaq
you are the man of the day and now let's
move on to the reuben report community q
a as i said we've got dozens of
questions over at
reubenreport.locals.com and if you join
right now there is a chance that i can
read a question on the fly we've got
helen and phoenix in the comment section
right now in the chat they are looking
and waiting for you guys to say
something brilliant or witty or
hilarious whatever it might be sam says
what are your thoughts on denmark and
several other european countries ending
all mandates and restrictions
looking for ways to get the usa to stop
with these crazy policies look my
socialist friends and you know i have
many socialist friends they often point
to the nordic countries they say look
how wonderful things are in sweden and
in norway and in finland and these other
countries look how wonderful things they
are and it's really usually a quite a
horrible comparison because these are
supremely tiny countries with very very
monoculture
uh situations going on there they're not
as socialist as you'd like them to
believe as bernie would always try to
point out uh but they have done some
things right and i've been to finland
i've been to norway i've been to sweden
i've been to a couple of the other
countries when i was on tour with jordan
really liked being there enjoyed the
people and and you know everything's
beautiful there and lovely and the
people everyone looks great and they're
tall and very nice
they've done something right here
they've done something right they've
just said enough's enough
i don't know if that's directly related
to the governments i don't know if it's
directly related to the people i don't
know if sanity somehow burst through the
ice when they were ice fishing for
salmon i don't know what's going on
exactly but obviously we should be
stopping with all of these mandates take
it from the swedes or take it from
shaquille o'neal but the governments
have failed us they have absolutely
failed us i'm pretty sure you guys know
a bit about the story of what's going on
up in canada the governments have failed
us so it's like justin trudeau look that
way and over there if you look further
enough you look far enough you're going
to find some of these nordic countries
and they decided to let their people
live freely why don't you try that too
man but i think we got more on justin
trudeau in just a moment
storm says hopping on a plane to juno
and i hope this will be answered after i
land what do you think will last longer
the freedom convoy or trudeau's
quarantine uh well good luck up there in
juneau um
so i guess trudeau is still can we con
officially confirm that is he in
quarantine still he's still he's still
i'm being told that justin trudeau is
still hiding in quarantine apparently he
had asymptomatic covet one of his kids
had it uh and he's hiding because he
just wants he wants faux sympathy
basically because he's really dropped
the ball here uh these these truckers
and their supporters they're not trans
so stupid they're not transphobes
they're not bigots they're not
anti-semites yeah like suddenly added
out of nowhere all of these people were
like you know i really have this
irrational fear of trans people and
we're gonna go occupy quebec you're the
name of that
it's just nonsense um i hope that some
of their demands are met uh actually we
are airing it today right i just
interviewed yesterday uh it's a short
interview about 15 20 minutes bj dictor
he is the spokesman for the entire
caravan you may have seen him on tucker
carlson a day or two ago and we dive
into a whole bunch of the issues we talk
about their demands and what what it
would take for them to say oh
we gotta win here and now let's let's
get out of there right like let's get
going so i think that that will
uh we're gonna post that today i'm being
told we're gonna post that today and
basically these people don't want
anything other than all of the rights
that they had two years ago they're not
asking for anything special they don't
want extra credit they don't want bonus
stuff they just want to live freely and
i stand with the truckers and i stand
against justin trudeau uh jeb says dave
could you tell us a bit about the
direction you want your one-on-one
sit-down interviews to go throughout the
year ah that's an interesting one you
know i'd love to get some of your
feedback on this i i got to tell you
i've mentioned this once or twice
in some of these live streams i'm really
enjoying this like i really like sharing
my thoughts with you guys i love doing
the q and a's but i mean when i mean
this i mean i really enjoy doing the
daily show when my guys we pick some
stories we talk about these things in
kind of a funny silly way you know we're
doing more
silly stuff the best comments when i
have time to look at comments the best
comments are that you guys watch the
show and you have a smile on your face
or you laughed a couple of times or you
don't you don't feel crazy about the
news all of the stuff
that that's why i do this like that's
what seems fun to me and if there were
more people doing it then maybe i
wouldn't have had to have done it
but that's the thing that i love so i'm
i'm actually not enjoying the interviews
as much as i used to you know i was sort
of early in on the podcast thing on the
long form interview thing you know when
i started doing hour-long interviews
that had sort of disappeared altogether
there were a couple of them sort of in
mainstream media still
you know larry king was already off of
uh cnn he was over at aura tv which then
they gave me a job which was pretty
awesome and larry became a friend and a
mentor and as i've said sort of a bonus
grandfather but there weren't a lot of
podcasts doing really sort of nuanced
conversations about a whole bunch of
stuff and i did it and we i guess did it
pretty well and i think i'm a decent
interviewer or at least some other
people do and that's just great um
and we've done it for a long time and
now you know everyone's kind of doing it
everyone's doing it everyone's doing it
in their own way and that's just fine
and i i actually don't well i love
competition i actually don't find that
i'm in competition with any of these
other interview shows it's like if you
like the way i interview somebody watch
if you don't you don't have to watch
it's all good um but in terms of like
the true like love of doing those
i i've actually lost a little bit of
that except with specific people when i
really find that there's like a real
reason to be talking to them like really
like are you are you charting new waters
you know are you really going somewhere
new my interview with glenn beck this
week and i love glenn and he's a friend
obviously like really talking about
what's behind the great reset what's
been happening for these last two years
someone who's been ahead of the curve on
most things like i really enjoyed that
but so i want to find new people to talk
to like people that are really
innovating starting new businesses
that think about politics in a different
way that maybe maybe we'll do more with
artists and musicians i'm totally i'm
totally open um but i don't want to do
just like the same old like political
machinations
over and over again uh you know some
stuff with politicians obviously but i
want to think about it and stay fresh so
i'd love more of your feedback on that
uh patrick says are you picking on
trudeau just because he's black
i'm picking on him because he's a woman
not because he's black it's mostly
because he is a trans woman i mean what
an idiot like really like
i just can't imagine i mean this is what
i say all the time like how could you
possibly be a canadian citizen and be
looking at what justin trudeau has done
for these last two years the endless
pandering the lying the destruction of
businesses stopping people from going to
church all of this stuff and think boy
this is the guy that i want in charge
and think how insane it is i mean the
guy won re-election during lockdown what
does that tell you about canadians i'm
not exactly sure except in the few
months since the election it's like
they've really turned on him so maybe
that maybe it took
you know the guy getting another term
for enough people to wake up to realize
it uh but it's a little bit like biden
right now it's like even if you let's
say you absolutely hated trump total
trump derangement syndrome you hate the
color orange you just could not vote for
trump and you voted for biden whether
you loved him or or just you just
couldn't do the trump thing whatever it
might be like how many people in america
right now we're just sitting around like
boy that joe biden's doing a hell of a
job
that joe biden is just great uh michael
how long did it take you to get your
couch
would you supposedly is arriving
tomorrow four weeks four weeks to get a
couch
i mean that's what's everything is slow
we're trying to build our studio
downstairs and it's like we just got the
the quote from the contractor and he's
like well with the supply chain stuff it
could actually take three months to get
a window literally a window a piece of
glass so if you're looking at these
people that are that are leading us
justin trudeau joe biden if you're
looking for these people going boy they
sure are doing a good job you know there
are people that are saying they're
economists that are saying that the
actual inflation rate right now is 15
so that means if you had a certain
amount of money in your bank account say
six months ago and you have the same
amount now it's worth 15 less because it
has 15 less purchase power
something ain't right here on top of all
the racism that they're bringing in and
all that kind of stuff uh olivia says do
you think places like florida are going
to see an influx of conservative
immigrants from the north from two
american loving canadians i hope so i
hope so i really think as long as people
know what they're fleeing
and know which way they're going to vote
i think places like florida like texas
like tennessee south dakota plenty of
other places
want to embrace new people coming here
with new businesses and good ideas and
bring your families and your values and
the the
all of the stuff all the stuff that
makes you you bring it to these places
that are flourishing i can tell you this
i visited my buddy
his mom lives uh in pompano beach which
is a little bit north of west palm beach
so it's about an hour north from miami
or so and she's in pompano and she was
telling us that her entire building
basically the entire building the condos
are all being bought by canadians who
are fleeing and
she happens to be somewhat like-minded
politically and we're chatting about it
and she was saying she's talked to some
of the people and they get it they get
it they know what they're fleeing so if
you know what you're fleeing by the way
that's very consistent with what goes on
here in miami you know the amount of
cubans that are here and venezuelans who
know what they fled they fled socialism
they're the most outspoken against this
nonsense so i think florida
texas tennessee etc should all become
havens havens for freedom and then let's
really let's really reinvigorate
ourselves with that let's really renew
it and there's plenty of room we got we
got a lot of everglades here right we
got marshes and swamps we can we can
build man we can do it uh mary says did
you and jordan discuss the state of our
spineless politicians on monday night
yeah there were a bunch of questions
about the trudeau thing which obviously
i've already hit here
the the overriding
point that jordan made that i've been
thinking about that i want to
incorporate into what i do going forward
so this is sort of related to the the
interview question is that so much of
what's going on politically is like we
need a good story right like our stories
our national stories our cohesive
stories have all kind of broken down
like what is the story of america at
this point it's hard to say right if you
listen to mainstream media corporate
press if you read the new york times or
washington post the story is somehow
that this thing is was always racist it
was fundamentally racist it's evil
capitalism's not good like that's the
story that they've run with and and
through that story they've destroyed an
awful lot and you got to give the devil
as do they did accomplish what they
wanted to accomplish so those of us that
love freedom that want america to
continue that think that this thing was
good we need a better story going
forward and i think our story is pretty
straightforward
we want you to live how you want to live
now we're going to have to fill that in
with some good characters maybe a little
cgi we're going to get some good writers
to to give a grand narrative around that
but i think one of the reasons that the
lefties are so hysterical all the time
is their story is not good so they need
hysteria they need anger they need to
pretend that they're fighting nazis and
for those of us that are kind of living
let live it's like we don't really think
about that kind of stuff a lot because
we're just kind of like oh i'm just kind
of doing my thing living my life it's
all right it's all good and we don't
spend time obsessing over politics
obsessing
over oh my god history was so evil and
all those things we look for places that
we can do a little bit better so i think
we have to figure out and when i say we
i mean i mean anyone basically non-woke
i don't really care what your political
differences are if you're non-woke we
need a better story to show
you know the average kid who's being
brainwashed in school
high school college doesn't matter
hey there's a better story over here the
story is that you can be the the main
character of your movie and you can do
that if the conditions for freedom are
there and that ain't what the other
guy's at it's just so much better on its
face that we just have to fill it in we
just have to give it a little color
sarah says without spilling too much on
classified info what are you looking
forward to the most this year regarding
both rumble and locals i mean we got
major stuff going actually it's a good
question because uh we will not have a
live show this monday because sunday
night and then into monday i've gotta
jump across the state again i'm going
over to sarasota where the rumble
offices are i'm giving a talk to all the
employees it's going to be one of our
first
uh real sort of get everybody in the
building we got
awesome awesome offices there on the
water like five boat docks like we're
gonna build something really awesome and
we're gonna have studios on the water
and it's really really great like we're
building something cool um so what i'm
excited about is there's such
opportunity
such opportunity you guys all know the
the spotify rogan situation that we were
talking about all week it's like spotify
has decided to put warnings up in front
of rogan's content now if rogan's okay
with that and that's what they want to
do and everybody's happy with that
that's just fine
i am intimately of involved in long
along with dan bongino
and chris the ceo and assaf the ceo of
locals in crafting what our policy will
be what is our policy around speech are
we going to put warnings on things we
don't want warnings on things if you
break the law you got a bigger problem
than us so you can put your content on
rumble that really is the policy that
we're all trying to craft perfectly
there's a lot of pieces involved in that
right um so i'm looking forward to
taking the opportunity as it exists the
more that those guys censor the more
that you guys tell me all the time you
don't see our videos in the youtube feed
or whatever it might be it's like well
we'll just build something that'll be
better and that's fun and that's what we
did for two years with locals and then
we found rumble and we were like well
these guys are doing some good stuff and
we met you know the ceo we met the
people behind it and we were like all
like hey we have some political
differences but who cares we all want to
fight the woke thing we want to fight
censorship we want to defend free speech
the best to the best of our ability so
let's let's keep going there so maybe we
can get some video of my speech on a
monday i'll see you about that uh travis
says when will you be touring florida so
we will be announcing my book tour soon
the book comes out middle of april uh
don't burn this country uh which we've
already sold a whole bunch of copies so
the new york times is not going to be
happy because they're going to have to
either put me on the list again or
they're going to have to be exposed for
not putting me on the list so that's
your warning new york times
um
but i will go go very very heavy in
florida like i would love to go to every
major city in florida even like however
we got to make it work i i just really
want to do it you know when i did the
event with jordan the other night it was
my first live appearance um live public
appearance in miami and it was just so
great like when the pa guy was like new
miami resident dave rubin and like the
crowd went nuts and it was just so great
to be out there and like
all the little silly things about miami
driving and the spanish and all the the
fun stuff like i just want to go all
over florida i do have
one public event in it's a semi-public
kind of private
public-ish event uh in naples in the
next couple weeks but i'm only going to
promote that for my locals community so
if you'd like to join you can otherwise
we'll get out there
in april and i'll bounce all over the
place and as i said i am not going to
tour in a place that demands vaccine
passports or mass mandates that's going
to cost you know cost me a bunch of
money it'll stop us from doing a certain
amount of venues and you know certain
amount of book sales and all that but i
just i'm just not going to do it uh
diana says which platform to view your
show helps helps to benefit the reuben
report more locals rumble or youtube i
want to make sure i'm giving you all of
the support i mean first i would say do
do whatever like
fits your life for whatever reason if
it's just easier for you to watch mobley
or at a desktop and you find one
interface better than the others look
locals in rumble are going to continue
to combine they're going to really
continue to combine we have a whole
bunch of features on the way
we're launching like a whole new feature
set um i can't i just can't tell you too
much just yet
but everything being equal if your
choice right now is to just watch the
live stream
between youtube and rumble uh it would
be better to watch on rumble because
youtube we just know they they have
their tricks you know and i just don't
think youtube's the future that's not
i'm not trying to pick a fight with
youtube i don't complain about youtube
anymore you know we get demonetized
sometimes i don't even bother publicly
fighting them anymore it's like they're
they're doing their thing it's been
really good to me in some ways and it's
been not so great in other ways it is
what it is that's the path they're going
down we're blazing a new trail with
locals in rumble that's the plan that's
the plan and that's what we're going to
do that's what we've done and it's what
we're going to continue to do
so everything being
being equal to live streams if you could
watch on rumble uh would be great but
subscribe on both why not right uh
richard says this was a
thought-provoking question i posted on
scott adams community page does having a
lack of humor correlate with the
inability to understand human motivation
you can tell who has a sense of humor
and who does not and it almost falls
along the left and right paradigm
curious on your thoughts oh i like that
question so it's interesting because
you know in the last two years or so
we've watched an awful lot of people
like just like lose their [ __ ] all
together i don't mean get some stuff
wrong like i've gotten some stuff wrong
okay like everyone gets some stuff wrong
but i'm talking about people that are
are saying the complete opposite of what
they used to say but not because they
evolved politically but because the
other side is in power or something like
that we've watched so many comedians or
i probably have to go like this with
comedians now comedians um who used to
be funny i suppose just become
hysterical
angry cancel culture enthusiasts you
know sarah silverman i never thought she
was that funny like she was in an
episode of seinfeld i like when she
dated kramer but like whatever she was a
comedian and just this hysterical angry
progressive nonsense chelsea handler the
same thing kathy griffin with the trump
head imagine if that had been done with
joe biden like these people that just
become really really angry i think
there's a lot of reasons for it patton
oswald who was sort of a funny comedian
at one time years ago i wanted him on
the show actually
where he has to issue an apology for
saying that he's friends with dave
chappelle
there is a connection
between an inability to be funny and
sort of modern woke progressivism
because it's it's a cult
it's a cult that doesn't let you
question it it's a cult that says these
are the things you can believe and now
you have to believe them and do not go
against anyone else there's no room for
comedy and that comedy is is comedy is
all about freedom right like comedies
where where it's messy and there's
different opinions and you can fight the
power and you can make fun of people and
it's like man wouldn't wouldn't it be
great if we had a guy like don rickles
back with us right now you know don
rickles the legendary comedian he lived
into his 90s passed away you know about
two years ago and it was like don
rickles used to walk on stage wherever
he was at a local comedy club in vegas
atlantic city i saw him give a a talk at
i think it was reagan's inauguration he
did a bit about this and he'd walk on
stage and make fun of everybody and make
fun of every ethnicity and skin color
and they brought everybody together
because there were no sacred cows oh my
god look at the black guy over there the
jew over there all the [ __ ] over
there but and he'd make fun of everybody
and sometimes people would be a little
offended but everybody was in on it
together we've decided or well i
shouldn't say we
many of our comedians and humorless
blowhards have decided that comedy can
only go one way which is why i have not
watched it in years but occasionally a
little snl clip will come across on
twitter and it's like man that is the
death of comedy there is nothing
nothing funny there and i always see
these think pieces you know new york
times and new yorker and these very
serious places they're always writing
about how comedy you know there's it's
been so bad between trump and then kovid
you know comedy is just there's no place
for comedy right now and comedy is dead
and then there are netflix netflix
specials by that woman i can't even
remember her name who was like the
anti-comedian comedian like she's so
funny she can't make you laugh something
like that it's like i don't know you
guys laugh a little bit during this
thing i laugh a little bit during this
thing i got no writers you know i'm just
telling you what i think so yes i do
think there's a connection
between sort of political ideology and
your ability to be funny if if you think
if if your whole world view is summed up
and you got to believe this freaking
thing where's the humor in that like i'm
pretty sure there aren't a lot of great
comedians in north korea there's
probably a lot of people who want to be
comedians but not a lot of great ones
that are out there right so comedy is
best done when the conditions for
freedom are out there so you can make
fun of the power you can make fun of the
politicians you don't view these people
as
as gods right and you believe that your
own thoughts have some value
not a lot of room for that over there
brad says even if there is a red wave
this year with the midterm elections do
you think that's enough to make people
to make people start to trust the
government again it almost feels too far
gone that's a good one um
well first off you know you don't want
to count your chickens before they hatch
is there every reason to think that
there's going to be a red wave yeah
right the democrats have just enough
people see it they've wrecked havoc
everywhere
the policing
the schools the wokeness the gender
stuff they've woke up parents they woke
up
canadian truckers even though that's not
our country they they've done something
that is so awful and there is just no
sane liberals and yes we can put the
little
bill mar box there okay but who are you
going to vote for bill maher that is the
problem right so i don't i don't want to
go down that road at this moment there's
just nobody to vote there vote for like
do you think that voting for chuck
schumer if he's not like a complete
lunatic radical is going to stop this or
nancy pelosi if she's not even though
she is like like the progressives they
did it they did it they just they rotted
out the party they destroyed the
liberals they did the whole freaking
thing
so
is there going to be a red wave that
would be my guess but again you don't
you don't want to walk into an election
thinking that there's going to be a red
wave you don't want to walk into a fight
thinking you're automatically going to
win this reminds me of what was it
probably around 92 when mike tyson
champion of the world mike tyson and he
was just mauling everybody and he would
beat guys in literally in 15 seconds in
the ring that michael spinks fight and
and he goes into the fight against james
buster douglas who nobody had heard of
and buster douglas beat the crap out of
mike tyson um remember that well that's
because of overconfidence right so you
don't want to walk into the fight and go
oh we're going to win obviously we're
going to crush over here everybody hates
the lefties the boasters or nuts and
everything else so we need to make sure
that we're all out there voting we gotta
we gotta be explaining our ideas doing
all of that stuff also the machine you
have to give the machine credit it
figures out ways to do all sorts of
weird stuff and brainwash people and
freak people out so anything can happen
but your question really was okay if the
if there's a red wave is that enough to
get get some trust back to the
institutions and to government
that will be up to those that we vote in
right that will be up to let's say in
virginia right now glen younkin has a
window okay man you wrote you ran
against critical race theory you you
decided to defend children against
these crazy out of control school boards
and everything else well now it's on you
so in a year from now we'll be able to
judge that i think if you bring in the
right politicians who just basically
stick to their guns basically you don't
have to be great guys you just can't be
horrible
if you can do that
then we got a chance to actually get
some trust back into these institutions
and that would be good even if even if
you're a complete libertarian or
anarchist
like you should want a little bit of
trust in some of these institutions
because otherwise we just don't have a
thread that brings us together
we just you need some trust in some of
these institutions and we don't have a
lot of trust amongst each other these
days so that would be the great
opportunity that's the story republicans
that's the story conservatives man you
see what those guys did
our story of freedom is better and if
you if you elect us
we will protect that that's pretty good
uh margot says have you thought about
adopting an iguana well first off you
know we did survive the big iguana
freeze of 2022 as you guys know we've
reported it here
breaking news on the reuben report uh
temperatures in south florida got as low
as 40 degrees and when it hits 40 that
apparently is the magic number these big
ass iguanas and some of them are up to
like three feet they're in the trees
they freeze they get comatosed and then
they just fall out of the trees they
thud on the floor they're not dead
usually i guess if you hit the floor
hard enough maybe you crack your skull
but they're just basically laying there
and then they don't wake up till it gets
warm enough although i would assume that
the vultures and some other predators
are probably taking a peek and seeing
what's for lunch uh but
we did not see any while we were walking
and i've been taking cloud on walks
we're getting a lot of peacocks around
here i posted an awesome video of two
male peacocks i mean have you ever
really been like five feet away from a
peacock these things are huge and
awesome and when they really like fan
out the feathers they're really
incredible you can you can take a look
at the video in the community um
but we did see
even though i didn't see any
comatose iguanas just on the floor just
like that we have seen a couple iguanas
that have been
mauled by cars so i don't know if that
was due to the comatose falling out into
the street and then getting hit by a car
or was just crossing the street
i don't know okay and we're going to
look into it but we have seen a few of
those and i'm pretty sure clyde's eaten
a whole bunch of iguana bones so would i
get an iguana i don't really need an
iguana in that i'm around a lot of
iguanas um but
maybe we'll get a second dog there's
been some discussion around that uh
brian says what's the cost of living in
florida compared to california is the
property tax in florida more or less
than in california glad you're enjoying
your move everything is cheaper here
everything is cheaper first off there's
no income tax so we're saving a ton of
money obviously which then i can hire
more people i can do more things we can
we can put more money into the house to
fix things i've got guys downstairs that
are fixing things right at this very
moment we can do more landscaping
whatever it might be we can build our
studio studio out as uh as big and
robust as we want to um everything is
cheaper here
what was it the other day we were
ordering something uh it was something
for the house like a chair or something
and we just looked at the tax and it was
like i ordered when i originally went to
the website i had my california address
in and then i realized it right before i
clicked purchase and then i put the
florida address in and it saved me like
14 bucks to order the exact same thing
because florida taxes are less so it's
just it really has just been great here
but it's not it's not just about the
money like
as i always said to you guys like i did
not leave california because of the
money you accept the high taxes you
really do for what socal can offer and
not just socal by the way there's plenty
of northern cali places that are
gorgeous sonoma is napa pretty freaking
spectacular you accept
the taxes as part of it but then when
the whole thing melts down i just didn't
want to fund my demise anymore so
everything here i have absolutely no
complaints some people said to me you're
going to move to miami south florida
it's very flat that's what they said
you're used to hills
in california you're used to hills i
like the flat i really do why i take
clyde for crazy long walks like we go
walking and we see the lizards we see
the peacocks it's great you know you can
see where you're going you don't have to
always be watching that a car is going
to swing by like some curve on the
mountain and whack you it's just great
here move here if you're a good person
move here and maybe i should be on the
board of tourism for florida can we talk
to the desantis people maybe i'll do
something like people move here and i'm
at the gate you know do we have a gate
we don't have a gate like a georgia
florida gate i could just stand there
and shake people's head welcome here's
an orange
janis says are you feeling hopeful about
that push for freedom across the world i
really am
i really am and i think if you can get
that
feeling inside of you even though facts
don't care about your feelings feelings
are important right
like it starts with hope right it starts
with hope looking for something in the
distance and going that's the thing i
want to get and i believe that there is
hope
when i when i left california now i've
said california again i will put five
more dollars into the flea california
thing we're up to let's say 75 bucks now
um
and i'm going to give i'm not kidding
i'm going to give all of the cash at the
end of the year to someone who reaches
out to me and says i want to flee
california
and i want to move to florida i'm just
going to hand you a whole bunch of cash
and i'll throw in some extra too at the
end
you have to have that distance you have
to have hope and when i was in
california after the recall and then i
got audited by the state and they
demolished larry elder and just saw all
these people who just won more there was
just no hope there but now what i'm
seeing between the truckers
who are actually affecting the
government
we covered it yesterday the premier of
alberta suddenly being like oh
i didn't want these mandates we're going
to figure out a way to shut this thing
down pretty quick we're going to let you
out free the fact that the nordic
countries are now opening up uh the fact
that there is such an obvious and stark
difference between a place like florida
at a place like new york it's like
yeah there's a lot of hope in that
there's a lot of hope in that and not to
sound uh redundant but i'm telling you
the dinners that i've been to here and
when i've met people here and when
people are coming up to me wherever i am
the new people especially
like they they understand what they fled
and if you really get it if you really
go even if you were a die-hard democrat
right if you left
san francisco and you were a nancy
pelosi democrat but then after the last
two years you realized
how
awful and evil the stuff that she's
doing is and you got to florida and you
go holy cow it's free and it's decent
and it's good and i'm telling you that
you you don't realize it when you're in
it when you're in
the machine when you're in a place that
everyone is just not really saying what
they think and they're masked all the
time and they're getting injected every
two weeks and they let the government
decide whether their five-year-old
should be ejected and all those things
you don't realize how it affects your
mind and your brain and your state of
being
so when i've had friends from la visit
like i did last week and they still live
there and they want to get here and
they're complaining about the needles on
the street and everything i was like
all right get going
it's up to you get going so it's up to
you so so yeah i am hopeful and the
final question i suppose this is
directly related to that stephanie end
of the week question could you be any
happier
um could i be any happier
i suppose there's always more room for
happiness right like you can always find
more happiness but i would say
pretty much within reason like this is
as good as it gets like i do work that i
love i work with great people i'm in a
relationship that makes me happy i we
just moved into a new house we're gonna
do lots of cool stuff here we've we've
got good friends i feel like i can go
out again
um you know maybe
you know what
i think i might go to a restaurant
tonight
i'm gonna go to a restaurant tonight and
breathe freely you know what i want you
guys to all go to restaurants tonight
okay everyone's going to all separately
all alone at a restaurant we're just
going to fill up the city um it's all
good like
i escaped the madness i escaped the
madness and it's good and um
you know jordan jordan yeah obviously i
mentioned jordan a lot but jordan
peterson often talks about that your
goal should not be happiness your goal
should be purpose because if you find
something that gives you purpose then
you'll find happiness but it's it's too
simple basically to say you're just
going for happiness like what would that
mean i'm going for happiness like i just
want to lay on the beach all day that
kind of sounds right at some level like
that would be nice to lay on the beach
all day every day but you might get
tired of it after a month like you can
only have so many my ties right and you
can only get so much sun so it's like
you what you shouldn't be going for is
just happiness but if you do something
that fulfills you like i feel like what
i do is relevant you know it feels good
i have something to say in the morning i
you know and i get that feedback all the
time and maybe the feedback can be kind
of dangerous because you get you get
negative feedback you get positive even
if i only got positive feedback all day
long i don't know that that would be so
great uh but i get up with purpose i
have something to do every morning i'm
very aware of that by the way like i
really am like i get up i have my coffee
i've been taking clyde for these walks
exploring the neighborhood and i'm very
uh i'm very aware and appreciative of
the fact that i get to do what i want to
do and then by me doing that i like to
think that some of the people that work
for me get to do what they want to do
for a living and then and then they can
do what they want in their lives and
then maybe if you watch this some idea
that either i said or some way that i
framed a story or somebody that i
interviewed like sparked something in
you so that you start doing something a
certain way like that's what being human
is all about that's what the exchange is
all about that's why we shouldn't want
to be censoring people if you've got bad
ideas they're gonna they're gonna fall
on the wayside um and i do i'm hopeful
for humanity and uh yeah i would say
i'm pretty happy and i got a couple new
bottles of tequila that doesn't hurt
does not hurt
uh guys my full interview with b.j
dichter who is the spokesman for the
canadian trucker caravan will be up
today on youtube and rumble uh part
three of my interview with glenn beck
all about the the great reset his new
book which really explores the whole
freaking thing will also be up today on
youtube and rumble the full episode with
glenn beck is already up ad free at
reubenport.locals.com
and uh all right i'm gonna i have a lot
i just had a lot of stuff to do at the
house it's up on blaze tv as well of
course i got a lot of stuff to do
at the house this weekend and as i said
no live show on monday because i'm
heading over to rumble in sarasota to do
a bunch of stuff but we will be back on
tuesday i thank you for watching have a
great weekend
see you tuesday